all right we have breaking news now  let's get to it it has to do with kovat  19 and the World Health Organization has  just declared a global corn corona virus  it is a pandemic at this point let's  talk about what that means the criteria  of a pandemic describes the worldwide  spread of the new disease involves a new  virus against which most people do not  yet have any immunity virus can infect  people easily and spreads  person-to-person we are seeing those  things it implies efforts to contain an  outbreak in a region or country have  failed a pandemic describes how  widespread and illness is not how  necessarily lethal it is the w-h-o has  said it is tightening its criteria  criteria for classifying an outbreak as  a pandemic and is working on a new  definition as it relates to corona virus